well let's go through this [ __ ] thing
I've worked on this all day what was
your first day in County Jail like okay
I only mentioned I kind of just go
through it real quick
I'm not real quick let's go through it
okay we got a nice little synopsis here
we're gonna go through so this is after
court you guess and it's what first day
you go to County Jail oh no what not get
sentenced no it's not like it was out
this is when they arrest me bring it
straight to [ __ ] right you're in jail
I walk in guys are all I remember guys
everybody staring I walked into a room
it was actually about the size of this
room maybe a little bit longer you want
those Coronis is like what booking room
no this is like your this is where the
beds are I've already been booked I walk
in and remember all the inmates are
staring at me there's like 20 guys in
this room this size all sleeping in this
room 20 22 guys I walk in they're all
staring at me and I'm thinking holy [ __ ]
and they're all looking at me and the
guy goes he points up and he goes you
were you were just on TV oh my god what
they were watching the news he was just
on TV see you you are uh he said
something about in cheese and you steal
a bunch of money from an insurance
company and somebody else goes banks bro
I should banks and [ __ ] you a gangsta
muhfucka you a gazer I thought holy Shh
I don't know what he's saying I mean
these guys are just I don't hang out
what they liked you
ya know what they didn't start stabbing
me which is what my concern was when I
walked and I looked at these guys I mean
it was like holy [ __ ] this is this is a
bad situation so I go in first thing I
do is I want to make a call I go pick up
the phone I can't figure out how to make
you use the phone punching in numbers
can't figure it out this [ __ ] black
guy comes over to me he goes yo he was
used time codpiece I'm sorry chalk eye
piece I'm I'm sorry
typey typey ban piece um
I start looking away look at around like
I don't know what the [ __ ] he's saying
he's speaking English right so this
white guy comes over he's got tattoos
he's got horns and [ __ ] on his [ __ ]
forehead and he comes over he goes I got
this he was you trying to call you
people and I know my people your peeps
kid mine I've never even heard the term
people come on I'm not keep on lying I
say that all the [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] um here's the epitome of white
privilege you've never been around
anybody I don't have been a
like I've I've been around you know
Spanish guys and some black guys if
they're they're doing the roof or
they're doing you know but I'm not or
they're they're educated I haven't been
around guys that are streaking they're
the street guys I've never met a street
guy so that the white guy comes up he
goes he said you trying to call your
people I got my people use your family
are you trying to call your family I was
like oh yeah yeah okay I got this
so he helps me use the phone I can't use
the phone you got pushed 50 numbers and
you got a clear inmate number and every
this was the beginning of a long journey
mad I remember walking to the to the
white guy after it you know you got
nothing to do your what there's one TV
out of 20 guys 15 of them are Spanish so
guess what channel you're watching the
Spanish Channel
Telemundo yeah so you're just sitting
there - all were doing is plain
you know chess and and talking so the
the guy's got horns on his head and I
went probably after a couple days you
seem like a normal guy and he goes right
I go you know I came in young I think I
told you this one time he came in he is
I went to a prison where guys were being
killed every week he was so I didn't
think I was gonna make it so you just
get crazy yeah he said then I finished
my state's sentence and I came here to
the feds because I had a Fed bid to do
he said and now I'm gonna be out in a
few and huh so he you know so you know
he's leaving so he's going to the feds
now and so now except for he he thought
he's gonna be dead in any day now he's
got tattooed [ __ ] spiral horns on his
forehead he's got all this now you're
getting now you're not getting a job at
the bank what were you thinking you know
he still thought he's gonna die so he
thought never he'll never survive it
right anyway so you meet all these guys
so I end up then when I eventually I get
transferred I get flown to Oklahoma City
but you get drive driven around in these
vans and [ __ ] it's horrible being
transported is the worst you get moved
around you end up going to Oklahoma City
and is it [ __ ] 8:40 yeah that is
ridiculous are the podcast till 7:45
Jesus God Almighty we've been talking
for an hour waiting on [ __ ] Oh over here
No
to do with me so I where are we getting
through this I mean we just started cuz
I'll talk like it you saw those all the
guys like I'll watch a six-hour podcast
yeah 60 or 80 guys then I'll watch six
hours you gotta go her captivating I
don't Danny might have to go on this
thing what he's got a wife that's I
don't got [ __ ] I'm authentically we mean
you could chat for I got all night Matt
okay so okay so so anyway I get
transferred I fly around I eventually
end up back at Coleman mm-hm I get
sentenced I go to Coleman when I go to
Coleman they send me to the medium first
because I had so much time at 26 here so
you got 20 years left you're just done
you know you you can't you couldn't
really sent me to a pen I can't go to a
low I go to the the I go to the media
might go straight when I go straight
into the housing unit where I'm supposed
to go I meet my cellie I think I
mentioned this we're going to tell you
that that I meet my cellie and then I
walk back out and then they start
screaming lockdown oh yeah somebody got
stabbed in the arm yeah he's like got
stabbed up a little yeah yeah he's like
oh somebody died he and he's like no no
someone just think I stabbed up the
first day yeah just stabbed him up a
little bit's the same thing Tampa Tony
told us when he went to prison for the
first day somebody got stabbed down yeah
yeah that's you know it's a bad
situation so yeah it can't be a good
situation I'm getting stabbed up a
little bit he's got poked a little bit
right yeah he survived right who knows
who knows I'm sure he's fine um you know
me guys I've met listen like 90 percent
of the guys that meet him have bullet
holes
they've all been shot everybody's been
stabbed everybody it's just ridiculous
so I mean yet the mindset there is so
rude it's so there's so much mental
health issues there's I got a whole wing
just four guys with mental health issues
bipolar they've got guys that there was
a guy named mr. Frese who had a
narcolepsy you fall asleep right what
happened mr. freeze they called him mr.
freeze because he had narcolepsy and
narcolepsy apparently like he would be
walking across the compound and just
fall asleep yeah but he wouldn't fall he
would if he was sitting down he'd fall
down he would walk and he'd suddenly
just stop and he just sit there for like
a minute or two and then they go just
and he start walking again and they call
them mr. fries guys that were in the
unit with them they said he'd be he
would be sitting in a chair watching TV
and all sudden he'd go and he fall out
of the chair and hit the ground boom and
lay there for a minute or two guys would
just look over in he get up get back in
his chair you tell me hitting the ground
didn't wake you up
holy [ __ ] so you know you know how he
ended up in the feds how he got some
first theft or something whatever
something stupid he ends up getting
going into the state prison and in
Florida well there's no there's no AC so
he's there and his cellie and he's like
he's complaining about how hot it is and
he goes oh you want you want a season
you got to go to federal prison he was
well how do I get to federal prison and
he goes oh man you could do anything you
could you just got to commit a federal
crime and you'll do all your state time
in federal prison yeah he's yeah he said
walk what's a federal crime years you
could threaten the president so he
writes a letter to Bush so at the time
he writes a letter to Bush and he says
he's gonna kill Bush and his entire
family and he's gonna rape the dog Wow
there's a little sprinkle on top yeah
yeah go ahead and so for good measure
Secret Service come they question him he
says yeah I wrote the thing they bring
him back to court gets him from the
court the judge the lawyer explains the
judge listen the guys
he's practically [ __ ] I mean you
know serum he had like issues and he's
like Your Honor this is what his cellie
had told him it's not in the judge goes
yeah but he wrote the letter
you know these judges they had no
silletti was like he's not even capable
of getting himself to Washington let
alone harming the president's ready
together
he's yeah but he wrote the letter he was
in it and I was told that he said that
the judge said on here's the fact that
he wanted to break the dog is disturbing
to me he said I'm gonna give him what he
wants though that was the golden ticket
of the letter he is going to federal
prison right after you finish your state
prison stint you're gonna go you're
gonna get seven years in the feds that's
why it was in the feds
hey know your Mike a little bit more a
little bit straight out more like that
like like this
yeah okay okay so um that's hilarious
yeah so is that how he got the mr.
freeze or cuz it was you know mr. freeze
was because he was like I said that MIT
works stop it works right and he didn't
get the AC he got the AC so it's mr.
freeze
and then they had another guy named
itchy itchy was a black guy who had hair
that he never combed it was like just
like just like a rock and itchy was
schizophrenic itchy like you know you
got afro like an afro but just like rock
like he never walked like it was yeah
hard you know if they don't they gonna
pick it out and yeah yeah it just gets
like knotted up it's a big dreadlocks
guys like a homeless guy yeah and you're
they have all these all these uh
walkways it she would walk right across
the grass look if I walked across the
grass I'm going the shoe if you would
walk right across the grass and the cops
would be like itchy is Jay mushy and he
and his he had a catchphrase which was I
still want my dick sucked so the cops
would yell at him and maybe like it you
come here and he Walker what what they
go told you not to walk across then you
go down the sidewalk and he'd go all
right all right
and he'd you're fine he start walking
off he got still want my dicks up and
they'd be like eh eh I mean it happened
he was it was he was crazy he walk up
and start yelling at guys to give him
coffee they knew he was how old was this
guy oh he had to be in his forties or
fifties Jesus so I was on at the time I
was taking a paxil and I was still I was
taking paxil and I was a I was those
what so it's a for it's a depression and
social anxiety so I have social anxiety
I don't like large crowds so I'm really
happy and I'm suffer from depression so
not good so I'm I'm in Pitt what they
call pill line mm-hmm so I'm standing in
pill line one day and itchy just walks
right across the grass everybody
screaming at him he walks right in the
front of the thing everybody backs up
like thoroughly Oh he walks straight the
front line gets his pills gets his pills
takes his pills and walks right back but
to the unit never really left the unit
much to accept it go get pills well
there's this guy going man that guys
[ __ ] crazy and there was a new guy
had just come to prison he got like five
or six years I don't even know why he
was in the the medium he's probably
shouldn't have even been there and I
looked at him and I went bro I said he's
a man that guys he sees mass that was
like a homeless guy he's all [ __ ] up
and then I go bro that guy right there
keep in mind most of your time is spent
trying to entertain yourself so you you
do stuff we would stay busy stay busy to
keep yourself entertained the vine
things that are funny or interesting
read books whatever so I'm sitting there
and I go that guy where that guy used to
own banks in the Cayman Islands and he
goes are you serious I went yeah bro I
said he was amok like like the cover
like Forbes magazine he had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jets and yes it used to be you
know like ten banks he was laundering
money like oh that dudes a [ __ ]
genius
[ __ ] itchy and he goes he is well
he's crazy I said well bro some people
this guy was complaining about how much
time he got like four years or five
years and I go well some people can't
handle the time they just snap and he
was like so I just [ __ ] you're with him
I know just cuz he's already been so all
this time I got like four years is like
four years
shut up man talk to me so you turned
yourself in you know my guys I know that
turn themselves in the they got like 10
15 years and turned themselves in you
got 15 years and you turns up Ron yeah I
got a shot Jordan got your time I can
talk to that guy so this guy's completo
and I tell him a couple days later I'm
in the chow hall and I'm sitting at a
table with a couple guys and it she
walks in walks up grabs his [ __ ] meal
and walks off and sits down at a table I
mean like it she was so nasty and
disgusting on somebody he'd sit at table
everybody would get up and move yeah
because he's you know so you didn't wait
in line so that he gets his food sits
down neck and the guy another guy I
don't know is telling another guy saying
well that guy that guy owned like 50
[ __ ] banks he's worth a billion
dollar story the story was like he was
on the cover of his fortune off Forbes
Wow
private jets and I'm like so someone
took your story and just [ __ ] crazy
that's amazing yeah it's hilarious
so what was it she actually in for did
Jerry say that
knows he's probably crackhead and some
conspiracy you'd be shocked there's
everyone's well there's some crackhead
that's like how did you even commit a
federal crime mmm it's like well he
happened to be one of 30 guys on a
conspiracy he's the lowest man that told
he's the guy that that is running back
and forth and the DEA comes in and guess
what you just got a federal crime should
be a state crime but the DEA was
investigating the top dogs and your
name's one of the many